Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Mustafa Celiq und ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistenzarzt tätig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Okay. Kurz zum Ablauf. Ich werde Ihnen so erst ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen
und danach werden wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Jonas Haller.
Jonas Haller.
Haller.
Okay. Können Sie bitte Ihre Vorname und Nachname bestabieren, Herr Haller?
Jonas schreibt sich J-O-N-A-L-S.
Ja.
Und Haller schreibt sich H-A-L-L-E-R.
Haller.
Okay. Das verstehe ich.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Haller?
61. 61 Jahre alt.
61.
Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. März 1962.
62.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Haller?
1,79 m.
Ja, meine Verbindung ist schlecht. Hab ich nie gehört, Herr Haller.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 m.
79. Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
83 kg.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, okay. Was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Haller?
Ja, ich hab so seit einem Tag, seit anderthalb Tagen,
habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Und die werden schlimmer.
Okay.
Seit anderthalb Tagen, ja.
Okay. Können wir,
könnten Sie bitte zeigen, wo die Schmerzen sind, Herr Haller?
Ja, die sind mehr so im Unterbauch,
in der Mitte vielleicht ein bisschen mehr rechts.
Okay.
Wie fangen diese Schmerzen in eine andere Körpferregion aus?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Nicht so eindeutig.
Also Sie sind wirklich mehr vorne im Bauch und eben im Unterbauch.
Ja, ausstrengend.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Haben diese Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich angefangen?
Die haben langsam angefangen, aber wurden dann ganz schnell auch schlimmer.
Langsam aber es ist schlimmer.
Können Sie den Charakter von Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich meine, sind Schmerzen eher dumpf oder krampfartig oder stehend?
Ja, das ist mehr so krampfartig, wie so eine Welle manchmal.
Dann wird er ganz stark.
Und das dauert dann einige Sekunden, halbe Minute
und wird er wieder etwas weniger, aber er bleibt, hört nie auf.
Okay.
Wellenförmig.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Okay.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf eines Kalafons 0 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leichten Schmerz und 10 sehr heftiger Schmerz entspricht?
Ja, ich würde sagen, wenn er gering ist bei 6
und wenn er stark ist, 8.
Ja.
Ich muss mir eine Notiz hier machen, deswegen kann ich dabei nicht ansehen.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Herr Schaller, haben Sie bemerkt, Essen, Bewegung oder Atmung, alle kann sein?
Ja, bei Atmung nicht.
Aber ich bewege mich nicht so gerne, jetzt, wenn das so weh tut,
dann sitzt ich zwar im Sessel oder ich sitze liege auf dem Rücken,
auf dem Zufall und ziehe die Meine etwas an, dann geht es manchmal etwas besser,
aber es ist nicht gut.
Aber das ist nicht Auslöser, das ist für schlechte Faktörer können wir sagen.
Auslöser, der Auslöser, ich weiß jetzt nicht den Auslöser.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Ich habe gestern Abend mal eine Schmerz-Tablette genommen, Paracetamol,
aber die nicht geholfen.
Okay, wie viel Milligramm war das Paracetamol?
Für Erwachsene.
Okay.
Aber nicht geholfen, ja?
Nein.
Okay, hatten Sie Unfall in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, kein Unfall.
Hatten Sie einige Beschwerden schon einmal in der Vergangenheit?
Nein, nicht so richtig.
Also ich war vor fünf Wochen beim Urologen.
Vor fünf Wochen, ja.
Vor Sorgeuntersuchung.
Und da war soweit alles in Ordnung, aber der Urologer meinte,
ich hätte da im Bereich der Leiste, hätte ich wahrscheinlich einen
Bruch und den soll ich mal bei Gelegenheit operieren lassen.
Und das will ich jetzt im Herbst machen lassen.
Jetzt nicht im Sommer, ich will noch in Urlaub fahren jetzt.
Okay.
Welche Leistung war das?
Am rechten Seite oder in den gesetzten?
Auf der rechten Seite ist das, das ist, ja, wenn ich die Leiste so abfühle,
ist es fast schon am Oberschenkel da, ist so eine Vorwölbung.
Okay, das ist ja.
Wenn ich da hin schaue, da geht so drauf, drücke, dann tut das da auch ziemlich weh.
Okay.
Haben Sie viel warst, Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Mir ist übel.
Ich habe jetzt zweimal verbrochen in der letzten zwei Stunden.
Ich kann gar nichts mehr essen.
Die letzten zwei Stunden haben Sie zweimal erbrochen.
Ja richtig.
Ja, wie sieht es aus?
Ich meine erbrochen gelblich, gelblich schleimig.
Ja, gelblich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Verstoffung oder Durchfall?
Herr Haller.
Normalerweise habe ich am Tag pro Tag zweimal Stuhlgang,
aber ich habe seit dem, dass ich jetzt angefangen habe, seit anderthalb Tagen,
habe ich bisher keinen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich schlopp oder müde?
Inzwischen ja, weil ich auch die letzte Nacht nicht gut geschlafen habe.
Oder kaum geschlafen habe.
Wegen Schmerzen, ja, Sie meinen.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendetwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ja, das kann alles sein.
Also ungewöhnlich jetzt nicht.
Wie gesagt, plötzlich kam dieser Schmerz.
Die rechte Seite da, am Leiste, am Oberschenkel,
die ist empfindlich auch.
Da kann man nicht so gut draufdrücken.
Aber sonst hat es ungewöhnliches bemerkt.
Okay, wie ist dieser Appetit, Herr Haller?
Normalerweise ist der gut, aber seit gestern ist der nicht gut.
Der Appetit, da habe ich auch kaum etwas geknickt.
Haben Sie seit anderthalb Tagen Schlafenprobleme wegen Schmerzen?
Hab ich geschrieben?
Aber in der letzten Nacht konnte ich nicht schlafen wegen der Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie haltrasen, Atemprobleme, Gusten?
Nein.
Oder ähnliches?
Okay.
Und seit, haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, glaube ich, mein Gewicht immer gehalten.
Das ist ein bisschen hoch, sagt der Hausarzt,
aber das ist nicht so weniger zu kriegen.
Ist Ihnen bekannt,
irgendwie als Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente ein gegen hohen Blutbrück.
Ja.
Seit ungefähr 10 Jahren.
Seit 10 Jahren. Welche Medikamente?
Das eine Medikamente heißt, die Tüde H, habe ich hier aufgeschrieben.
Die Tüde H und davon nehme ich eine morgens.
Die Tüde H.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Können Sie stabilen oder?
Die Y, T, I, D, E und ein großes A.
Okay.
Wie viel in welche Dosierung nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Weiß ich nicht, welche Dosierung ich hier nehme.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch Ramie Briel 5.
Eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay.
Morgens und abends.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren, Herr Haller?
Ja, als Kind Blindermoperation.
Und als ich 25 war, hatte ich einen Motorradunfall.
Und da war der Oberschenkel gebrochen.
Und da wurde der Oberschenkel mit einem Nagel versagt.
Mit Nagel.
Als die 75 Jahre alt, ja.
Mit 25 Jahren.
Ja, hatte ich den Unfall.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Und Blindermoperation, als Sie Kind war, können Sie...
Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau, wie alt ich.
Da war ich 8 oder 9.
Okay, das ist egal, ja.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, ich war in Österreich im Winter.
Da bin ich im Wintersport gewesen.
Aber da war ich nur eine Woche.
Okay.
Ich nehme noch ein Medikament ein.
Weil ich schon mal 2-mal Gicht-Anfälle hatte.
Im großen C.
Hallo, Porinol, nehm ich ein.
Hallo, Porinol steht dahinter 300.
Nehm ich eine Tablette morgens.
Okay, alle Porinol.
Eigen Gicht.
Wie...in welcher Dosierung, dass ich meinen Terben...
Das ist nicht sehr gut.
Hallo, Porinol, 300.
Ja, okay.
Dankeschön.
Haben Sie irgendeine allergien, Herr Haller?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay, und Lebensmittel-Unverträglichkeit,
vielleicht haben Sie?
Zum Essen her kann ich alles vertragen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Haller?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber wenig.
Vielleicht 2 Flaschen Bier in der Woche wegen meinem Beruf.
Da kann ich auch gar nicht viel Alkohol trinken.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
2 Flaschen Bier.
Jedem Tag oder?
Ein pro in der Woche.
Okay.
Die folgende Frage ist eine Routine-Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit dem Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Das ist gut.
In der Familie gibt es die Falle von Krebs
oder Erdkrankheiten oder irgendeine Krönchen-Krankheiten?
Ja, der Vater war nicht ganz 60 Jahre alt.
Ich glaube 59 hatte er Darmkrebs.
Daran operiert worden.
Er ist erst dann mit 82 Jahren verstorben.
Da sagte der Arzt, das wäre Herzschwäche gewesen.
Es wird mir leid.
Er hatte Darmkrebs mit 59.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Aber der Arzt hat gesagt, das war ein Herzinfarkt.
Herzschwäche.
Ja, okay.
Er ist mit 84 Jahren verstorben.
Er hatte Asthma.
Und auch Herzschwäche.
Ein Bruder, der ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Er hatte vor zwei Jahren auch Darmkrebs.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Er ist operiert worden.
Es geht ihm aber gut.
Alles gut geht.
Brüder, Darmkrebs.
Und zwei Jahre.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Taxifahrer.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Zwei Kinder.
Sie sind 28 Jahre alt und 30 Jahre alt.
Sie leben aber nicht hier in der Stadt.
Sie leben woanders, aber denen geht es gut.
Okay, das ist gut.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, Sport treiben tu ich nicht.
Ich interessiere mich für Fußball, aber da schaue ich mehr am Fernsehen zu.
Aber selber spiele ich nicht mehr.
Früher habe ich mal Fußball gespielt, aber das ist schon lange her.
Ja, jetzt Herr Haller, ich glaube, dass ich alle wichtige Fragen gestaltet habe.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja.
Was kann das sein? Was habe ich?
Ja, ich möchte erklären, was ich machen werde jetzt.
So erst, wir sollen ein paar Untersuchungen und Labordiagnostik durchführen.
Herr Haller, ja, es ist jetzt so, früher etwas zu sagen.
Ich werde Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Aber so erst, ich soll Ihre Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz, Körpergewicht,
Körpertemperatur und Blutdruck kontrollieren.
Und dann werde ich eine EKG durchführen, um mögliche Herzimpagnen auszuschließen.
Das ist wichtig für uns.
Und ich lege, ich untersuche Sie ausführlich,
außer dem untersuche ich Ihre Bauch, Ihre Bauch, so erst körperlich und dann mit dem Ultraschall.
Mit dem Ultraschall habe ich mir viele Informationen über Ihre Atomenorgane.
Kann ich jetzt noch etwas essen?
Ja, es wäre besser, wenn Sie etwas nicht essen,
weil das kann schlechter Wirkung auf Therapie und Diagnose.
Deswegen, Sie sollen etwas abwarten.
Ja, ich habe jetzt gerade relativ viel Durst.
Wie ist das mit Trinken?
Ja, wir können so machen.
Ich lege eine große, wenn es so geht.
Und dann können wir etwas Wasser im Gefäße geben.
Was heißt, wie nöser Zugang?
Ja, wenn es so bedeutet, ich werde ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Deswegen, wir brauchen einen Zugang, ein Gefäß-Zutritt,
ja, ein Tritt, können wir sagen.
Dann fühlen Sie sich besser nach dem Eingriff.
So können wir das machen.
Gut.
Okay, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe andere Fragen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie sagten, dass in Ihrer Familie Darmkrebs festgestellt und behandelt worden sei.
Haben Sie sich aus diesem Grund schon einmal untersuchen lassen?
Nein, bisher noch nicht, aber auch das hat mir mein Hausarzt geraten.
Sollte ich jetzt wirklich machen, aber ich möchte zunächst erst mal im Herbst
mir das operieren lassen, am Bein diese Vorwölbung da.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, seit an der Tat,
Sie hatten keine Zugang.
Ich würde gerne wissen, hatten Sie seit Beginn Ihre Bauchschmerzen
gehn, Winde ab?
Ja, im Anfang, aber jetzt so in letzter Zeit, in letzter Stunde nicht mehr so.
Wie sieht Ihre Ürin aus, Herr Halle?
Ja, der Urin ist glaube ich jetzt relativ dunkel, aber ich habe auch wenig getrunken
jetzt in den letzten Stunden.
Jetzt habe ich ebenso starken Durst, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, weil mir übel war
und ich erbrechen musste, dass ich das nicht mehr behalten.
Deswegen habe ich auch nicht viel getrunken.
Sie haben gesagt, Wellenformen und Krampfartike Schmerzen haben.
Können Sie ein bisschen genau beschreiben?
Ich würde einfach ein bisschen dumpf sein.
Okay, danke schön.
Was, was, andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen?
Nein, beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Der Patient hat schon gesagt, kein Problem im Wasserlassen.
Schönerlende Schmerzen in Leistenbereich?
Nein.
Also ich habe gesagt ja auch, dass diese Stelle, diese dicke Stelle da in der Leiste oder am Beginn des Oberschenkels,
dass die jetzt schon etwas empfindliches und weh tut, wenn ich da draufbrücke.
Ich drücke da nicht mehr drauf. Ich kann auch keine enge Hose da haben.
Das ist schon empfindlich da.
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl gesehen?
In den letzten Tagen oder so?
Nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Seit gestern haben Sie in der rechten Leistung ein Schwellung bemerkt.
Die Schwellung war schon vorher da. Die ist bei Aufreffenden beim Urologen,
als ich beim Urologen zur Krebsvorsorge war.
Da hat der Urologe gesagt, im Bereich da ist eine Vorwirkung und er sagt,
das wäre wohl ein Bruch.
Er hat mir geraten, dass ich den bald operieren lasse.
Und das will ich im Herbst machen lassen jetzt.
Aber ich will vorher noch in Urlaub fahren.
Aber jetzt kamen die Schmerzen so heftig.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, ein Gift-Anfall haben.
Bei meinem 2-Bahn hatte ich Gift-Anfall im Großzeg.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Seitdem bekomme ich eben diese Tabletten für erhöhte Hansare.
Wann wurde diese Diagnose festgestellt?
Der erste war vielleicht vor 7 Jahren.
Und dann war vielleicht der andere vor 6 Jahren.
Die waren relativ schnell hinter einem da.
Und seitdem nehme ich jetzt dieses Medikament.
Danke schön.
Können wir erst mal beginnen, Herr Haykorn?
Okay.
Für mich auch okay.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Darf ich Ihnen vorstellen?
Ja, können Sie?
Okay.
Mein Patient ist Jonas Haller.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,79 m groß.
Und 83 kg schwer.
Und er ist am 14.3.1962 geboren.
14.3.
Ja, 3.
Okay.
14.3.
Herr Haller hat sich wegen seit 1,5 Tagen bestehender, bestehender,
wellenformiger Bauchschmerzen im Unterbauch vorgestattet.
Die Schmerzen schmiert sich allen nicht.
Irgendwas für per Region nicht.
Im Laufe der Zeit haben sich diese Schmerzen zerschlechtert.
Er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen krampfartig sind.
Bei Bewegung verschlechtert die Schmerzen.
Und gestern hat er 500 mg Parastomol eingenommen.
Aber es hilft nicht.
Es hat nicht geholfen.
Vor fünf Wochen war er bei Urologin.
Eine Ingrenal-Herrni wurde festgestellt.
Aber Herr Haller hat diese Information früher.
Er hat schon diese Verborgung bemerkt.
Als begleitende Symptoma können wir sagen, hat er Übelkeit.
Und in zwei Stunden hat er zweimal erbrochen.
Oder wir können sagen, er hat Neusea.
Und er hat zweimal Emesis.
Erbrochen sieht gelblich aus.
Und ein bisschen Essenreste.
Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Letzte Stuhlgang war.
Seit 1,5 Tagen hat er keine Stuhlgang.
Wie war das Stuhlverhalten vor dem Schmerzeeigen?
Das ist ungewöhnlich.
Normalerweise hat er Stuhl.
Zweimal.
Seit 1,5 Tagen kein Stuhl.
Das können wir ungewöhnliches annehmen.
Er fühlt sich müde.
Seit 1,5 Tagen hat er Stuhl.
Seit 1,5 Tagen hat er keine Appetenz.
Okay, in Appetenz.
Er hat Distumni wegen Schmerzen.
Er hat als vegetative Anamnesikung
Schlachtstörung und Distumni.
Er hat keine Erkrankungen.
Er hat Blutdruck.
Er hat Hypertonitis.
Hypertonitis?
Ja, Arthéa-Hypertonitis.
Er nimmt die Tür.
Die Tür der Haar?
Ja.
Er nimmt diese Medikamente einmal täglich.
Aber wie viel?
In welcher Dosierung weiß er nicht?
Ich kann das nacharbeiten.
Das ist nicht ganz entscheidend.
Er nimmt sonst noch Medikamente?
Ja, er nimmt 5 mg 2-mal täglich.
Alle Perinol 300 mg.
Warum?
Ja, wegen Gift.
Er hatte 2-mal Gift-Atheke.
Wegen Hyperurikemi?
Ja, wegen Hyperurikemi.
Er schluchte nach 2-mal Arthritis-Urika.
Im rechten Großzehn Grundgelenk.
Im Klammern Podagra.
Podagra.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Arthritis-Urika ist wichtig.
Hyperurikemi.
Hat der Patient voroperationen im Bauch?
Ja.
Er wurde appendectomisch.
Bei ihm würde appendectomy durchgeführt.
Als er Kind war.
Im Kind ist ein appendectomy.
Ja, okay.
Und als er 25 Jahre alt.
Würde bei ihnen
eine Operation durchgeführt.
Ich glaube, das tut mir leid.
Ich glaube, das tut den Endeportest.
Ein Nagel.
Im Alter von 20 Jahren
wurde ein Nagel durchgeführt.
Ein Nagel durchgeführt.
Ein Nagel durchführt.
Das macht es sehr gut.
Den Nagel wird EQ.
Es gibt ein Nagel der in dem Femur,
für Stabilisierung.
Es braucht Platin.
Da kann man sagen Femur Nagelung.
Wenn ich bin,
ist das ja auch eine Ostiosynthese.
in der Familiengeschichte? Ja, ihr Vater und Bruder hatten
Darmcrabs oder ich glaube das war Coloncarcinom, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Laut Patient besteht eine ausgeprägte familiäre Coloncarcinom-Belastung,
wahrscheinlich mit 59 und 1, mit 61 glaube ich. Und ja das wird mir jetzt ein,
Eltern haben, beide haben Herzinsuffizienz. Das können wir auch genetisch veranlagen,
genetische veranlagen sein. Nein, 80 Jahre, ich bin keine Genetische.
Es ist glaube ich zu alt dafür, aber sicherlich eine familiäre Disposition zu...
Ja, es könnte sein. Und, ich habe das die Diagnose.
Das ist die Diagnose. Ja, meine Veldacht Diagnose ist ein Problem mit Darm.
Ja, aber es kann ein Ileus sein, nach meiner Meinung, oder ein Divertikulüt sein.
Die Veldacht Diagnose ist Ileus. Ja, der Ileus ist die Konsequenz aus was?
Ja, aus einer Obstruktion. Und woran denken Sie da bei der Schilderung des Patienten?
Ja, ich wünsche es könnte einen auch Coloncarcinom haben.
Aber denken Sie an den Urologen. Was hat der Urologen?
Ja, ja.
Carcerite herrnien.
Es besteht offensichtlich bei dem Patient eine hernie.
Ja, ja. Ingrinal hernie.
Es ist eine ingrinal hernie oder eine femoral hernie.
Der Patient hat geschaut, es ist ein Knubbel da am Oberschenkel, so ein bisschen da oben.
Und der tut ihm jetzt sehr weh. Ja, mitrecht, ja.
Bei der vorgeschlechtheit muss man eher an eine inkarcerierte hernien Ding im Bereich der Herne.
Ich glaube eher eine femoral hernien.
Diese femoral hernien Bedarf in der Regel der akuten Versorgung.
Ja, natürlich.
Der Patient hat ja schon eine Iliosympathik entwickelt.
Erbrechen, keinen Stuhlgang mehr, Schmerzen.
Da muss man dann sicherlich im Rahmen, es ist ein akutes Abdomen,
muss man auch dann relativ schnell handeln.
An der Skoloncarcinom würde ich jetzt nicht denken.
Ich habe extra das Skoloncarcinom als familiäre Disposition genannt.
Der Patient richtet ein normales Gewichtsverhalten in der letzten Zeit.
Das Spulverhalten war bisher auch unauffällig.
Bis auf die Frage, der Schmerz ist mehr rechts unten.
Und eben im Bereich dieser geschilderten Vorvölbung,
die der Urologie gefunden hat, würde ich in erster Linie an eine inkarcerierte hernien denken.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und differential diagnostisch, sicherlich kommen andere Dinge in Betracht.
Natürlich muss man auch denken, auch wenn er vor Jahren voroperiert wurde,
kann ein voroperierter Bauch auch Jahre später noch Probleme machen.
Politisch würde ich von der Schmerz-Lokalisation eher im linken Unterbauch als Siegwärter.
Politisch denken oder Mittelbauch.
Poloncarcinom war eine kleine Falle von mir.
Ja, wir sind ja nicht gemein, vielleicht können wir denken, aber das ist ja nicht so.
Ja, das ist ja nicht gemein. Meistens Oberbauch in China als in...
Ja, auch.
Wichtig ist jetzt, ich denke, Sie haben das alles sehr systematisch auch gemacht.
Bei der Abfrage der chronischen Erkrankungen sind Sie sehr schnell stehen geblieben.
Ja, Sie haben, ich habe Ihnen genannt, Hyper-Blooch-Blooch, die Medikamente,
und ich habe dann, sozusagen, nachdem Sie da nichts mehr gefragt haben,
von selbst erwähnt, ich nehme noch ein anderes Medikament.
Die Frage, da bitte weiter, haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen,
so chronische Erkrankungen.
Bitte daran denken, wenn Sie das schildern,
Herr Haller ist ein 61-jähriger Patient, der seit anderthalb Tagen
über abdominelle Schmerzen klagt, haben Sie zuerst,
Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen, okay.
Und Sie gleich den medizinischen Fachbegriff dazu nehmen.
Es geht ja um die Vorstellung beim Oberarzt.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Schmerzen, VHS zwischen 6 und 8, wellenförmig,
das kann man sagen, und dass Sie dann auch nicht die Begriffe nennen,
statt Übelkeit erbrechen, das haben Sie dann korrigiert,
aber möglichst gleich nennen.
Okay.
Und erhöhte Harnsäure, das ist die Hyper-Urichemie,
und der dritte Urika, der Gichtanfall,
wenn Sie dann noch den Begriff Podagra nennen,
das ist eben dann der Gichtanfall im Großzehngelenk,
wäre das optimal, aber das muss ja nicht sein.
Aber wichtig ist, dass Sie möglichst diese Fachinformation nennen.
Gegenüber den Patienten haben Sie, denke ich,
sich sehr verständlich und gut ausgehalten.
Sie haben sich entschuldigt dafür,
dass Sie hin und wieder den Patienten nicht anschauen,
weil Sie ja schreien, das ist alles so.
Ich habe extra nachgefragt, was ist denn ein venöser Zugang?
Ja, das versteht viele Menschen nicht.
Wenn man da, müssen Sie einfach sagen, ich nehme in Blut ab
und lege Ihnen dann eine Infusion, damit Sie nicht mehr so viel Durst haben.
Weil ich habe ja extra gefragt, kann ich etwas essen.
Sie sollten gerade ein bisschen denken, Sie dürfen ab jetzt hier
nichts mehr essen und trinken, deswegen bekommen Sie von mir
eine Infusion.
Dann haben Sie alles erklärt.
Aber ich so denke, ich habe das für mich sehr verständlich
und systematisch gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, es ist natürlich etwas gemein gewesen,
Sie als Haltsinwurzel-Ohrenarzt mit einem dummen,
beschwerten Bild zu konfrontieren.